Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest ishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers and manage payroll
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要获取每周独家播客节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestisaphistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestisaphistory.com。本集由 SAP 赞助。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的企业提出更高要求，现在是时候尝试 SAP 了。它的人工智能功能可以帮助您精简成本、连接新供应商并管理薪酬
even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too so your business can stay unfazed learn more at sap.com slash uncertainty this episode is brought to you by sap with investors customers and workers demanding more from your business it's time to try sap it's AI powered capabilities can help you streamline costs connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people
即使在您的企业面临多重压力、需要以合理的价格交付高质量产品，同时还要支付给员工应得报酬的时候，也能让您的企业稳如泰山。了解更多信息，请访问 sap.com/uncertainty。本集由 SAP 赞助。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的企业提出更高要求，现在是时候尝试 SAP 了。它的人工智能功能可以帮助您精简成本、连接新供应商并管理薪酬，即使在您的企业面临多重压力、需要以合理的价格交付高质量产品，同时还要支付给员工
what they're worth too. So your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. Check out the big stars, big series, and Blockbuster movies. Streaming on Paramount Plus. Cue the music.
应得的薪酬。从而让您的企业能够从容应对。访问 SAP.com/uncertainty 了解更多信息。观看大明星、大剧集和大片。正在 Paramount Plus 上热播。播放音乐。
Like NCIS, Tony, and Ziva. We'd like to make up her own rules. Tulsa King. We want to take out the competition. The substance. This balance is not working. And the naked gun. That was awesome.
比如《海军罪案调查处：托尼与齐娃》。我们喜欢打破常规。《塔尔萨之王》。我们要消灭竞争对手。《某种物质》。这种平衡不管用了。还有《白头神探》。太棒了。
Now that's a mountain of entertainment. Paramount Worth. Hello, everybody. Welcome to this very special Rest is History bonus episode with the head of Disney Bob Eiger. Now, Tom, normally our bonus episodes are only for members of our much-loved Restis History Club. But this is one is a little bit different, isn't it? Yeah, so this week we've done two episodes on Disney. We looked at the man himself and we looked at Disneyland.
这才是真正的娱乐盛宴。Paramount Worth。大家好。欢迎收听这期非常特殊的《The Rest is History》特辑，嘉宾是迪士尼首席执行官鲍勃·伊格尔。汤姆，通常我们的特辑只针对我们备受喜爱的“The Rest is History俱乐部”的会员开放。但这期节目有点不一样，对吧？是的，所以本周我们做了两集关于迪士尼的节目。我们探讨了沃尔特本人，也探讨了迪士尼乐园。
And also, of course, if you're a member of the club, you would have got to listen to the coda to our epic series on Nelson, where we talked about what happened to Lady Emma Hamilton after Nelson's death. But in this special bonus episode, we are with Bob Iger. and we are discussing with him Walt Disney's legacy with the man who now runs Disney. So a very unusual bonus episode for us, a bonus bonus episode, in fact, hope you enjoy it. So Bob, here we are. Amazing setting, stage one here at Burbank. And we've just come from Walt's office, which you showed us.
当然，如果你是俱乐部的会员，你还能听到我们关于纳尔逊的史诗级系列的尾声，我们在那里谈到了纳尔逊死后艾玛·汉密尔顿夫人的命运。但在今天的特别特辑中，我们邀请到了鲍勃·伊格尔，我们将与这位如今掌管迪士尼的人一起探讨沃尔特·迪士尼的传奇。所以这是一期非常不寻常的特辑，实际上是一个“特辑中的特辑”，希望大家喜欢。鲍勃，我们到了。环境太棒了，伯班克的1号舞台。我们刚从沃尔特的办公室过来，你带我们参观了那里。
And you're one of, I guess really three people in the majority of Disney's history who've run the company. And, I mean, no offense, but you're not going to be running it forever. No offense, take it. That's good. I hope I'm not. So what do you think, you know, we've talked a lot about Wolfe's legacy, but what do you think your legacy will be when you look back on your time
我想，在迪士尼漫长的历史中，你大概是仅有的三位掌管过这家公司的人之一。而且，说实话，你不可能永远掌管下去。没关系，请说。这很好。我希望我不会永远掌管。那么你认为，正如我们讨论了很多关于沃尔特的传奇，当你回顾自己作为
as the kind of custodian of this amazing, well, the captain, this fantastic ship? Yes, I think about this often, actually. And I think because of the company's place in the world, I think the person running the company has a special responsibility of sorts to maintain Disney's position in the world as a beloved company, as an admired company, as a company that entertains really the world, everyone, of all ages and from all different walks of life. And I think more than anything else, I would want to be known as someone who was given the keys to this kingdom, so to speak, and quite a kingdom it is. and that I brought it to a place that even Walt would be proud of. And what that means is more great storytelling to a larger audience, more innovation, more risk-taking, more really creation of happiness.
这个神奇王国的守护者——或者说这艘伟大巨轮的船长——的这段时光时，你认为你的传奇会是什么？是的，我其实经常思考这个问题。我认为，由于这家公司在世界上的地位，掌管公司的这个人肩负着一种特殊的责任，即保持迪士尼在世界上的地位：作为一个备受喜爱的公司、一个令人钦佩的公司、一个真正为全世界、为所有年龄段、来自各行各业的人带来娱乐的公司。我最希望的是，人们能记住我，认为我接过了这个王国的钥匙（可以这么说，而且这是一个多么了不起的王国），并把它带到了一个甚至能让沃尔特感到骄傲的高度。这意味着为更广泛的受众带来更多精彩的故事叙述、更多的创新、更多的冒险，以及创造更多真正的快乐。
It's really that simple. At one point, I thought, well, okay, you're now running Disney. What's the most you want to have? Well, not, don't screw it up, but it's much more than that. I really have been mindful of. the duty that I feel has been handed to me to make it even better than it's ever been. And what do you think the years ahead hold for Disney? Because you've been at the forefront of so much technological change going back to Walt
事情其实就这么简单。有一段时间我想，好吧，你现在在掌管迪士尼了。你最大的愿望是什么？嗯，不是“别把它搞砸”，而是要远超于此。我一直铭记着肩负的责任，要把公司带到比以往任何时候都更好的境界。你认为迪士尼的未来几年会怎样？因为从沃尔特时期开始，你就一直走在众多技术变革的最前沿
and effectively inventing animation, as we were talking about earlier, but also you're a company rooted in history. So how do you think Disney and your successors will navigate that? I think you would both probably agree. It's hard to project 50 years ahead about anything, really. because the world is changing so rapidly and in such profound ways. And, you know, as I think about the future, one, I would hope that my successors would be respectful of our past and well aware of the values that really created the value of the company in the first place
并且实际上发明了动画，就像我们之前谈到的那样，但同时你也是一家植根于历史的公司。那么，你认为迪士尼和你的继任者将如何驾驭这一点？我想你们两个大概都会同意，对任何事情预测50年后的未来都是很难的，因为世界变化太快、太深刻了。你知道，当我思考未来时，首先，我希望我的继任者能够尊重我们的过去，并且深刻理解那些最初创造了这家公司价值的价值观
and carry them forward, but not let anything that's been done in the past get in the way of bringing the company into the future, and that's really constant innovation. a constant exploration, you know, constant essentially desire to reinvent or to invent, even. More than anything else, that's what I'd want. But I think we do occupy a place in the world as great storytellers, perhaps maybe the greatest. And I would hope that that position would continue for years and years, decades ahead. And talking of great storytellers, obviously, it would be very out of character, Tom, us, not to talk about ourselves in this context.
并将它们传承下去，但又绝不让过去所做的事情成为公司迈向未来的绊脚石，而这实际上就是持续的创新、不断的探索，你知道，本质上就是不断重塑甚至发明的渴望。最重要的是，这就是我所期望的。但我认为我们在世界上确实占据着伟大故事讲述者的地位，也许是世界上最伟大的。我希望这种地位能够在未来的岁月、未来的几十年里一直延续下去。说到伟大的故事讲述者，显然，如果我们不顺便谈谈我们自己，那就太不符合我们的风格了，汤姆。
So how did you get into the rest of this history, could I ask? Well, actually, a colleague of mine here at Disney, Christina Shaki, who was our chief communications officer and as a history buff, I think, recommended it initially. We share an interest in nonfiction, particularly books about history, and she was the first that suggested I listened to it. And I think during COVID, it served a great purpose. I went for many walks and liked to listen to a variety of different things, podcasts and music. And it was just a wonderful way to occupy time in what was obviously a pretty tricky time of our lives.
那么，我想问问你是怎么接触到《The Rest is History》的？其实，我在迪士尼的一位同事克里斯蒂娜·沙基（Christina Shaki），她是我们的首席通信官，也是个历史迷，我想最初是她推荐的。我们都对非虚构作品感兴趣，尤其是关于历史的书籍，她是第一个建议我收听的人。我想在新冠疫情期间，它发挥了很大的作用。我散了很多步，喜欢听各种各样的东西，包括播客和音乐。在当时那个显然相当棘手的时期里，这绝对是消磨时间的一种绝佳方式。
And are the particular subjects from history that have really fired your imagination? This is a commercial for the rest of history, I guess. We're all in favor of that. What I love about it is that, one, it gives me the ability to tap into things that I've already been interested in, and I know a little bit about, and you teach me more, but you also introduced me to subjects that I wouldn't have been even curious about. The recent one about Marie Antoinette comes to mind.
有没有哪些特定的历史主题真正激发了你的想象力？这大概是给《The Rest is History》做的一个广告吧。我们都很乐意。我喜欢它的地方在于，首先，它让我能够接触到我原本就感兴趣、略知一二的事情，而你们教会了我更多；但同时，你们也向我介绍了那些我甚至不会产生好奇心的主题。最近关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的节目就浮现脑海。
On the other hand, I was always fascinated with the Titanic, and your multi-partner on the Titanic filled in so many blanks for me and created so much more context. I also, an officianto of certainly American history, particularly American presidents. Yeah. So the assassination of Lincoln comes to mind
另一方面，我一直对泰坦尼克号很着迷，你们关于泰坦尼克号的多集节目为我填补了许多空白，并创造了更多的背景信息。我也是美国历史的爱好者，尤其是美国总统的历史。是的。所以林肯遇刺案这件事，我特别感兴趣。
is one that I was particularly interested in. One I recently listened to about Reagan in the attempt on his life. Yeah. He also found interesting, looking back, I think, at 1968 and Nixon and the anti-Vietnam movement. Yeah. So, of course, Custer, which was one of the all-time grades.
我最近听了一集关于里根以及他遭遇暗杀未遂的节目。是的。回过头来看，我也觉得很有趣，比如1968年、尼克松以及反越战运动。是的。当然还有卡斯特，那是史上最伟大的节目之一。
I don't know, is that over yet? 133 parts. Yeah. Still going strong. He eventually died, fortunately, I guess. Yeah. I think we still carried on after he died. So to give you a sense of how the rest of it.
我不知道，那个系列结束了吗？133集。是的。依然在持续更新中。幸运的是，他最终还是死了，我想。是的。我想在他死后我们还在继续更新。所以为了让你们感受一下《The Rest is History》
to Sissue Work, but this is not a production process that I would recommend at Disney. We were originally scheduled to do one episode, which would be 55 minutes, and there was a point at which we'd reached, we'd done about eight or nine, and Theo and Tabby, our producers, left their mics on, and they were, I could hear them bitterly complaining that the series had now swollen to about 10 hours. Because I think originally, we were going to do the entire history of Native Americans in four episodes. Yeah.
是如何制作的，这可不是我会在迪士尼推荐的制作流程。我们原本计划制作一集，时长55分钟，但当进行到大约第八集或第九集时，我们的制作人西奥和塔比把麦克风忘了关，我能听到他们愤怒地抱怨这个系列现在已经膨胀到了大约10个小时。因为我记得最初，我们打算用四集讲完美洲原住民的整个历史。是的。
And that just proved impossible. It did prove impossible. So, yeah, not a model for Disney planners. Would you have any areas of history or themes that you would particularly like us to explore? I've studied and read a lot about Churchill, and I know you've touched on Churchill here and there, but I don't think you've ever done a full birth to death of Churchill. We've done young Churchill, but we have been talking about carrying his life forward, aren't we? And our competing impressions of Churchill.
结果证明这根本不可能。确实不可能。所以，是的，这绝对不是迪士尼规划者的模范标准。你有没有特别希望我们探索的历史领域或主题？我学习和阅读了很多关于丘吉尔的内容，我知道你们在这里或那里提到过丘吉尔，但我觉得你们从来没有做一个完整的、从生到死的丘吉尔生平。我们做过年轻的丘吉尔，但我们一直在讨论继续讲述他的生平，对吧？以及我们对丘吉尔的不同印象。
I think that's what the bubble really wants. He was, you know, he was maybe a larger-than-life figure to Americans, too. At least Americans born when I was born. I was born in 1951. And so he was not only very much alive, but very much active in politics still. And I still remember him coming to the United States for the funeral of John F. Kennedy and thinking, here's a man that was born, I believe, in Victorian England, attending the funeral of a man who was one of the youngest presidents ever elected. I just remember thinking about.
我想这正是听众真正想要的。你知道，对美国人来说，他或许是一个传奇般的人物。至少对我这个年代出生的美国人是这样。我出生于1951年。所以他不仅活着，而且仍然非常活跃于政坛。我依然记得他为了参加约翰·F·肯尼迪的葬礼而来到美国，当时我想，这是一个生于维多利亚时代英国的人，却在出席一位有史以来最年轻当选总统的葬礼。我记得自己一直在思考。
about that span of history. But I was struck, we did a series on the assassination of JFK and kind of looking at his early life. And I hadn't properly appreciated the way in which he was knitted in to the world of high society in Britain. So he would probably, I mean, he knew Churchill before the war. His sister married, someone who then married a Mitford.
关于那段跨越历史长河的思考。但令我印象深刻的是，我们曾制作过一个关于肯尼迪遇刺案的系列节目，探讨了他早期的生活。我以前并没有真正理解他如何深深融入英国的上流社会。所以他可能——我是说，他在战前就认识丘吉尔。他的姐姐嫁给了一个后来娶了米特福德家族的人。
Is that right, I can't remember exactly. His father was ambassador, he was then to the court of St. James. Yeah. and also had a thing or two to say about the rise of Nazism, which is now I know that's something that you've also covered. Yeah, that's right. Now, something we're always asked by our Restis History Club members,
是这样吗？我记不太清了。他的父亲当时是驻圣詹姆斯宫的大使。是的。而且他对纳粹主义的崛起也发表过一些看法，我知道这也是你们探讨过的话题。是的，没错。现在，我们的“The Rest is History俱乐部”会员经常会问我们一个问题——
our beloved members of the Restis History Club, they always ask us, Tom, who would you like to have dinner with from history? Bob, it would be remiss of us not to ask you. So if you could have anybody from history for dinner, you could take them to Disneyland and have dinner with them. Who would it be? Well, it would have to be Walt Disney.
我们备受喜爱的“The Rest is History俱乐部”会员，他们总是问我们，汤姆，你最想和历史上的哪个人共进晚餐？鲍勃，如果我们不问你，那就太失职了。所以如果你能邀请历史上的任何人共进晚餐，你可以带他们去迪士尼乐园共进晚餐，会是谁呢？那一定得是沃尔特·迪士尼。
Yes, and I think about it often. People always ask me, what would Walt think? Right. You know, it's interesting, too, because one of the things that was problematic for the company after Walt died so suddenly in 1966 is the company spent so much time asking that question, what would Walt do or what were going to think. So I'm not really interested in turning to him for advice, per se, but I would be more interested in showing him what's become of the great company that he founded.
是的，我经常这样想。人们总是问我，沃尔特会怎么想？没错。你知道，这也很有趣，因为在1966年沃尔特突然去世后，公司面临的问题之一就是公司花了太多时间去问那个问题：沃尔特会怎么做，或者沃尔特会怎么想。所以其实我并不是真的想向他寻求建议本身，我更感兴趣的是向他展示他所创立的这家伟大公司如今变成了什么样子。
And I wouldn't mind a bit of a report card. Perhaps it's cocky of me to think that he would give me all A's. Which at the rise do you think he'd be most impressed by? Well, you know, he is, I know because you've done a little studying of Walt, he never even considered them rides. They were all stories to him, they were experiences, he wasn't building rides. And many of the, not just traditions, but values that he created and essentially built, We followed basically through on essentially either his instructions or his vision.
而且我也不介意拿一张成绩单。也许我认为他会给我全A，这显得有点自大。你觉得他会对哪项游乐设施印象最深刻？嗯，你知道的，我知道因为你对沃尔特做过一些研究，他从来不认为那些是游乐设施。对他来说，那全都是故事，都是体验，他建造的不是游乐设施。而且许多——不仅是传统，还有他创立并本质上建立的价值观——
And so when we create attractions, we try to tell stories when we create attractions. Even when we create restaurants and hotels, there's a story behind it. And in particular, I'd love to show them what we built that's derived from Star Wars mythology. We call the Lands Galaxy's Edge. There's one in Florida and one in his beloved Disneyland. By the way, they're a billion-dollar lands. And they not only tell great stories, but as he really demonstrated back when he built Disneyland in the 50s into the 60s, he used technology to make those stories as compelling as possible in physical form, which is not easy. And these attractions in Galaxy's Edge, there are two main attractions, are an unbelievably perfect example of the blend of great technology with great storytelling in the physical world.
我们基本上都是沿着他的指示或他的愿景继续走下去的。所以当我们创造景点时，我们试图在景点中讲述故事。甚至当我们建造餐厅和酒店时，背后都有一个故事。特别是，我很想向他展示我们基于《星球大战》神话建造的园区。我们称之为“银河边缘”园区。佛罗里达有一个，他钟爱的迪士尼乐园里也有一个。顺便说一句，这是耗资数十亿美元的园区。它们不仅讲述了伟大的故事，而且正如他在50年代到60年代建造迪士尼乐园时所展示的那样，他利用技术以实体形式让这些故事尽可能引人入胜，这并不容易。而“银河边缘”里的这些景点，其中的两个主要景点，是实体世界中伟大技术与伟大故事完美融合的不可思议的绝佳例证。
Yeah. And I'd love to him to see that. And very expensive. And he loved spending enormous amounts of money on achieving his films. Well, you know, yes, I guess he spent loads of money in what he did. And then he made lots of money. I'm not sure that he ever thought. It was always to him, in my opinion, about how can I tell this story better? Or how can I tell a great story? And I don't think he even asked what it will cost. No. And that's why poor Roy was, oh no, you've done what? You've bought what? Yeah. By the way, I noticed that.
是的。我很想让他看看那个。而且非常昂贵。他喜欢花巨资来拍好他的电影。嗯，是的，我想他在自己的事业上花了很多钱。然后他赚了好多钱。我不确定他是否考虑过成本。在我看来，对他来说永远都是：我怎么能把这个故事讲得更好？或者我怎么能讲一个伟大的故事？而且我认为他甚至不会去问这会花多少钱。绝对不会。这就是为什么可怜的罗伊总是：哦不，你又干了什么？你买了什么？是的。顺便说一句，我注意到了这一点。
I should admit this too publicly, but often when we dream up ideas here, the first question we ask ourselves is not how much will it cost, is can we make it great? And then eventually you get to the, well, what is this going to cost and doesn't make sense, because we're trying to serve shareholders as well as customers. But that is a Walt Disney inheritance, isn't it? I mean, that was very much his approach. It is. And I think actually, if you ask what everything is going to cost before you make everything
我也应该公开承认这一点，但通常我们在构思点子时，我们问自己的第一个问题不是“这要花多少钱”，而是“我们能把它做到极致吗？”然后你最终才会去想，“好吧，这要花多少钱，这有意义吗？”因为我们在为股东服务的同时，也要为客户服务。但这是沃尔特·迪士尼留下的遗产，对吧？我的意思是，这很大程度上就是他的方法。确实是。而且我认为，如果在你制作任何东西——甚至在考虑制作某事之前——都去询问每样东西要花多少钱，那么你最终就会放弃很多本该制作的好东西。是的。所以这和查塔姆高街是一样的。非常有查塔姆高街的氛围。那么在讲故事方面，有没有什么故事是你任职迪士尼期间非常渴望讲述，却没能如愿的？
or even think about making something, then you end up not making a lot that you should have made. Yeah. So that's the same with Chatham High Street. Very much the Chatham High Street's vibe. So on the storytelling front, are there stories that you would have loved to have been able to tell during your tenure at Disney but weren't able to?
有什么错过的故事，或者你希望迪士尼在未来讲述的故事吗？这是一个有趣的问题。我其实从来没有想过我们有什么还没做的事。我们总是满脑子想着我们能做什么。如果你看看我担任这个角色的任期，我为我们能够讲述的一系列精彩故事感到非常自豪，其中一些是通过收购公司实现的，从2006年收购皮克斯开始。我想到这些艺术家和讲故事的人多年来讲过的精彩故事，从《头脑特工队》到《寻梦环游记》，我可以一直说下去。
Are there any of that got away or stories that you would like Disney to tell in the future? That's an interesting question. I've really not thought about what it is we have. haven't done. We're always dreaming about what it is we can do. And if you look at my tenure in this role, I'm very proud of the array of great stories that we've been able to tell, some through acquisition of companies, starting with Pixar in 2006. And I think about the wonderful stories those artists and storytellers have told over the years from inside out and up to Coco, and I could go on and on.
然后，当然还有漫威以及我们在那里讲述的故事。显然，《黑豹》和《复仇者联盟》脱颖而出。最后是在2012年从乔治·卢卡斯手中收购了卢卡斯影业，并基本延续了他创造的神话——我认为这应该被视为我们有生以来创造的最伟大的神话之一——讲述更多《星球大战》的故事，然后收购了二十世纪福斯，并与詹姆斯·卡梅隆合作潘多拉和《阿凡达》系列电影，等等。
And then, of course, there was Marvel and the stories we've told there. Obviously, Black Panther and Avengers stand out. And then ultimately buying Lucasfilm from George Lucas in 2012 and continuing basically the mythology that he created, which I think should be considered among the greatest mythology created, at least in our lifetime, and telling more Star Wars tales, and then buying 20th Century Fox and working with Jim Cameron on Pandora. And Avatar films, for instance.
所以，当我们展望未来时，有如此多的故事正计划去讲述，以至于这真的不是关于我们错过了什么。而是，我们如何把所有这些故事都做好？我们拥有难以置信的奢侈，你知道，拥有数之不尽的宝贵财富。你漏掉了布偶秀。因为我想我们确实顺便拥有了布偶秀。我们实际上正在为布偶秀筹备一些项目。哦，那是个好消息。
So, and as we look ahead, there are so many stories that we're planning to tell that it's really not about what we're missing. It's, how do we get all of these right? We have an unbelievable luxury of, you know, just great riches. You missed out the Muppets. Because I guess we do own the Muppets along the way. We're actually working on something for the Muppets. Oh, that's good news.
那是个好消息。我确实很喜欢布偶秀。这是一个很有趣的现象，不是吗？因为你扮演的角色和沃尔特·迪士尼扮演的角色，在历史上并没有太多类似的类比。有些人领导过帝国、民族国家等等。但实际上，我的意思是，对一个就坐在你几英尺外的人说这话可能有点奇怪，但你拥有的权力比许多通过选举产生的首相还要大，
That's good news. I do like the Muppets. It's an interesting one, isn't it? because the role that you've had and the role that Walt Disney had, there are not many analogies in history. There are people who've led empires and nation states and whatnot. But effectively, I mean, this is a strange thing to say to somebody sitting just a few feet away from you, but you have more power than a lot of elected prime ministers,
不一定是对人们的日常生活，而是对人们的思想、人们的想象力。你曾经想过这一点吗？这会在你脑海里盘旋吗？嗯，我当然不认为自己是个皇帝。不，我不去想权力，我思考的是一个伟大故事的力量，当然，但我不认为我们有多么强大。我认为我们拥有奢侈的条件——这既包括与伟大艺术家合作的奢侈，也包括拥有资源向世界讲述精彩故事的奢侈，并且希望通过我们的讲故事对世界产生积极的影响。当然在当今世界，仅仅是能够让真正数以亿计的人
not necessarily over the day-to-day lives of people, but over people's heads, people's imaginations. Do you ever think about that? Does that ever play on your mind? Well, I certainly don't consider myself an emperor. No, I don't think about, I think about the power of a great story, of course, but I don't think about us being powerful. I think about us having the luxury of, and that includes both the luxury of being involved with great artists and the luxury of having the resources to tell wonderful stories to the world and hopefully through our storytelling to have a positive influence on the world. Certainly in today's world, just the ability to make really billions of people.
快乐，就是一种不可思议的奢侈，也是我一直铭记在心的事，但我并不认为这是拥有权力，除了或许拥有行善的权力。哦，那太好了。所以这与我们形成了鲜明的对比，对吧，汤姆？因为我们一直在反思我们巨大的权力。是的，但我只想行善。是吗？你只想作恶。
happy is an incredible luxury and something that I'm very mindful of, but I don't think about it in terms of having power except maybe the power to do good. Oh, that's nice. So that's a contrast with us, isn't it, Tom? Because we do reflect on our enormous power. Yeah, but I just want to do good. Do you? You just want to do evil.
没错。这就是我们之间的区别。但这正是让事情取得成功的平衡。是的，这就是阴和阳。顺便说一句，在讲故事方面，你们两个可能会赞同这一点。我们在讲述这些故事时面临的最大挑战之一，就是弄清楚反派到底是怎样一个人。你们一直在讲关于反派的故事。反派的动机是什么？
That's true. That's the difference between us. But that's the balance that makes the progress successful. Yeah, that's the ying and yang. By the way, in terms of storytelling, you may both appreciate this. One of the biggest challenges we have when we tell these stories is figuring out what the villain is all about. You tell stories about villains all the time. What is motivating the villain?
为什么反派会这么邪恶？其实并没有。我们最终必须将他们描绘成反派，首先是因为我认为人们喜欢关于正义与邪恶的故事，尤其是正义战胜邪恶。但讲述那些真正解释是什么驱使这个反派变得如此糟糕的故事……嗯，这其实是这个节目最迷人的地方之一。而且在没有任何宏大意图、只是试图讲好一个故事的情况下，就是去走入那些与你有不同假设的人的内心，对吧？所以我们做了一集关于纳粹的节目，试图解释为什么
Why is the villain so villainous? No, they don't. And we ultimately have to portray them, one, as villains. Because I think people love stories about good and evil, particularly good, triumphing over evil. But telling stories where you actually explain what is driving that villain to be so. so damn nasty. Well, that's one of the fascinating things with the show, actually. And without any great, with any attempt to tell a good story is to get inside the heads of people who have different assumptions from you, right? And so we did an episode about the Nazis to try to explain why
他们觉得自己并没有做错。是的，为什么他们不觉得自己是邪恶的？这通常可以是一种——我想这其实与写一个伟大的虚构故事没什么不同，因为你是在进行一种想象力的行为。你必须把自己放在别人的鞋子里。我想，这就是历史和虚构共同的迷人之处，即想象力的行为。所以我们不久后就要去迪士尼乐园了，必须得说，我们对此感到非常兴奋。我想你第一次看到迪士尼乐园是在电视上。你当时在纽约长大，奥申赛德，我想是吧？我在一个叫奥申赛德的小镇长大，但我最初住在纽约布鲁克林。
they thought that they weren't about it. Yeah, why did they not think they were evil? And it can often be a, I guess it's not unlike writing a great fictional story in that you are, it's an act of imagination. You have to put yourself into somebody else's shoes. And that's one of the fascinating It's one of the things that history and fiction have in common, I suppose, the act of imagination. So we'll be heading to Disneyland shortly, which we're very excited about, I have to say. You first saw Disneyland, I guess, on TV. You were growing up in New York, Oceanside, I think it is. I grew up in a town called Oceanside, but I lived in Brooklyn, New York originally.
没错。我们在那里有一台非常小的黑白电视机。没错，正是在那里，我第一次在ABC电视网播出的节目中
Right. And that's where we had a very small black and white television. Right. And that's where I experienced Walt Disney and Disneyland. for the first time in a program that ABC carried on its network. Yeah, because that ABC connection was really important, wasn't it, to raise the money for Disneyland. And what did Disneyland mean to you growing up at that point in time?
体验到了沃尔特·迪士尼和迪士尼乐园。是的，因为ABC的那个联系非常重要，对吧，为迪士尼乐园筹集了资金。在那个时候，迪士尼乐园对你成长意味着什么？
I guess paradise, you know, utopia. Talk us through what it kind of represented. Walt was, as we know, not only a great storyteller, but one of the all-time great salesman of his time. We forget that, that, you know, another aspect of Walt's town. was his salesmanship. And he decided that not only to raise the money, but also to sell the product, he should have a television program. So he licensed to ABC, a program that essentially told the story of building Disneyland. And so here I was as a three, four, five-year-old watching on a small black
我想大概是天堂吧，乌托邦。给我们讲讲它当时所代表的意义。正如我们所知，沃尔特不仅是一个伟大的讲故事的人，也是他那个时代最伟大的推销员之一。我们常常忘了这一点，你知道，沃尔特的另一个方面
and white TV. Walt not only talk about building Disneyland, but watching it on the program actually rise from the ground in Orange County, California. And I remember it being incredibly aspirational, and I think actually it served that purpose to hundreds of millions, not billions of people around the world, seeing it, which seemed like something that never existed before, a form of entertainment that he really invented.
就是他的销售才能。他决定，不仅为了筹集资金，还要为了销售产品，他应该制作一个电视节目。所以他授权ABC播放一个基本上讲述建造迪士尼乐园故事的节目。于是，当时三、四、五岁的我就坐在一台小黑白电视机前，
It wasn't, and I can't wait to show it to you, because it is not an amusement park at all. It's a concept unto itself. The idea of filming an experiment and a project that could so easily have gone wrong, I mean, that is expressive of Cajones. Yes. Yes. Of an order that he repeatedly displayed throughout his career.
不仅听沃尔特讲述建造迪士尼乐园，还在节目中看着它在加州橙县从平地拔起。我记得它具有极强的激励作用，而且我认为它实际上对世界上数以亿计、甚至数十亿看到它的人起到了这种作用。这看起来像是以前从未存在过的事物，一种他真正发明的娱乐形式。
Yes, and look, I admire so much about Walt. I'd say one of the things I admire the most is his guts. I won't use the term that you used because I'm a Disney guy. I'm more G-rated than perhaps you guys are. But he had unbelievable guts. Actually, more than guts, it was courage. Yeah. He had a vision.
它不是——我迫不及待地想带你们去看看，因为它根本不是什么游乐园。它本身就是一个概念。构想一个稍有不慎就会彻底失败的实验和项目，我的意思是，这简直是太有种了。是的。是的。这展现了一种他在整个职业生涯中屡次表现出来的
He was almost always convinced that his vision was right. And he had the confidence to attempt to really to execute it. And that's both confidence in the ability to basically build successfully, but also the ability to look really above and beyond the naysayers and those that said it can't be done. And if you said something couldn't be done, Walt said about to do it. It was that simple. And so I watched this ambition actually almost jump out of the screen.
魄力。是的，看呐，我对沃尔特充满了敬佩。如果要说我最敬佩他什么，我会说是他的胆识。我不会用你们刚才用的那个词，因为我是迪士尼的人。我的评级比你们可能要更合家欢（G级）一些。但他有着不可思议的胆识。其实，比起胆识，那是勇气。是的。他有一个愿景。
And I remember it as a kid. And you couldn't help but want to go there. Because, again, it was so new. It was so, it seemed so big, so fresh. So just almost extraordinary. And actually, it's interesting. I was thinking back building, bringing Disneyland to Shanghai. So here we were in the earlier part of really this century wanting to plant a Disneyland flag of sorts in China
他几乎总是坚信自己的愿景是正确的。并且他有信心去尝试并真正将其实现。这既是对成功构建能力的信心，也是能够超越那些唱衰者和说“这不可能做到”的人的眼光。如果你说某事不可能做到，沃尔特就会着手去做。事情就是这么简单。所以看着这种野心几乎从屏幕里跃然而出。
and thinking about not just what we would build, but whether it would become the beacon to people all around China that Disneyland was to Americans in the 50s. And it's interesting, that actually has happened that a lot of people in China are well aware of Disneyland. It serves as the number one tourist attraction in Shanghai. Millions, tens of millions of people have visited it, which is tiny compared to the total population of China. But as we have done research, we've discovered that people's desire to visit. And by the way, we open Shanghai Disneyland on national television in Shanghai, just as Walt had done with Disneyland in 1955, learning from Walt, not just how to market, but how to
我小时候就记住了这一点。你情不自禁地想要去那里。因为，再次说明，它是如此新颖。它是如此巨大，如此新鲜。简直几乎是非凡的。而且实际上，很有趣。我回想当年把迪士尼乐园带到上海。所以当时在本世纪早些时候，我们想要在中国插上一面某种形式的迪士尼乐园旗帜，
ignite an interest. And it's just, it's such an interesting entertainment experience that when you see it, even in, you know, on the screen, you almost feel you have to visit. So when we're going to Disneyland, what should we be looking out for? What are you most looking forward to showing us? Well, first of all, you have to look at how other people are experiencing it. You'll see wonder on their faces. You'll see a rush to get through the gates and get to their favorite attraction. you'll see children and their parents and grandchildren and friends and groups of people from all different kind of collections of society walking in with a sense of wonder on their faces.
并思考不仅我们要建造什么，还要思考它是否会成为中国各地人们心中的灯塔，就像50年代迪士尼乐园对美国人那样。有趣的是，这确实发生了，中国有很多人非常了解迪士尼乐园。它成了上海排名第一的旅游景点。数以千万计的人参观过它，虽然相对于中国总人口来说这只是很小的一部分。但正如我们所做研究所发现的，人们想要参观的渴望……顺便说一句，我们在上海电视台全国直播中开幕了上海迪士尼乐园，正如沃尔特在1955年开幕迪士尼乐园时所做的那样，向沃尔特学习的不仅是如何营销，还有如何点燃兴趣。这真的是一种如此有趣的娱乐体验，当你看到它时，甚至是在屏幕上，你都会觉得自己非去不可。所以当我们去迪士尼乐园时，我们应该注意些什么？你最期待向我们展示什么？
So look at the people first. I still, by the way, and I don't know how many times I've been to one of our parks, it's the first thing that I experienced, the first thing that hits me, really, when I walk in, is, my goodness, look how these people are enjoying themselves. And it's an incredibly powerful feeling to have. So watch that. You'll see immediately things that were absolutely from Walt's vision,
首先，你必须观察其他人是如何体验它的。你会看到他们脸上的惊叹。你会看到他们争先恐后地穿过大门，奔向他们最喜欢的景点。你会看到孩子、他们的父母、祖父母、朋友，以及来自社会各界不同群体的人们，带着惊叹的神情走进来。
Castle and Main Street and things that are obviously referenced from older America. There's a lot of history there. But I think you should also look at how much we've continued to invent and expand. And as he was fond of saying, as long as there's curiosity left in the world, Disneyland will never be finished. And can I know, I've never been, but the vision of the future was important to Disneyland. So has the vision of the future evolved over time? Well, the vision of the future is harder today. Walt's vision of the future, and I'm envious of him doing this in the 50s, when so much of future stories really had not been told, at least in physical form.
所以首先要看人。顺便说一句，我依然——我不知道我去过我们的乐园多少次了——这是我每次走进去时感受到的第一件事，也是冲击我的第一件事，那就是：天哪，看看这些人玩得多开心。这是一种感觉极其强烈的体验。所以去观察这一点。你会立刻看到那些完全源自沃尔特愿景的事物，
You know, I can remember growing up in the 50s and being fascinated by Sputnik, and ultimately, the early age of space travel with both the Russians and then the American space program. And I remember them demonstrating a telephone where you actually, which had a television. Imagine making a call and seeing the person on the
比如城堡、美国大街，以及那些明显参考自旧时代美国的事物。那里有很多历史。但我认为你们也应该看看我们在持续创新和扩展方面付出了多少。正如他常说的，只要世界上还有好奇心存留，迪士尼乐园就永远不会完工。我能问一下吗——我从未去过——对未来的展望对迪士尼乐园一直很重要，那么对未来的展望随时间演变了吗？嗯，今天的未来愿景更难把握了。沃尔特对未来的愿景——我真的很羡慕他在50年代就能做到这一点，当时关于未来的许多故事甚至还没有被讲述，至少没有以实体形式呈现。
other end. And I think at some point maybe there might have been a reference to microwave ovens. Well, you know, you guys are younger than I am. I remember a day when they didn't exist, but you probably don't. And so it's harder today to tell the story of tomorrow.
我记得自己在50年代长大，对人造卫星（Sputnik）以及俄罗斯和美国太空计划开启的太空旅行早期时代着迷不已。我记得他们展示过一种电话，你可以一边通话，还能看到另一端的人。想象一下打个电话就能看到对方。我想在某个时候可能还提到了微波炉。好吧，你们比我年轻。我还记得它们不存在的日子，但你们大概不记得了。所以今天要讲好明天的故事变得更难了，
because I think in technology has done this so much of, you know, what is around the corner. Now we have AI, which maybe that's even endless in terms of what the future looks like. I think it just gets harder. And the future of a Disneyland itself continue to evolve, I guess, more attractions, constant innovation. So having been to Disney World, one of the things that struck me thinking about the generations of people going, is there's an element of nostalgia to it, too, isn't there? It's a place of safety and security and sort of old-fashioned values to some degree. So I guess will Disneyland continue to kind of try to strike that balance between those two things?
因为我认为技术已经把接下来的发展揭示了太多。现在我们有了人工智能，也许在未来的模样上这甚至是无止境的。我认为这只是变得更难了。而迪士尼乐园本身的未来将继续演变，我想，会有更多的吸引力，持续的创新。去过迪士尼世界后，触动我思考去那里的世世代代人的事情之一，就是其中也包含着一种怀旧元素，对吧？它在某种程度上是一个充满安全感、保障和某种老式价值观的地方。所以我想迪士尼乐园会继续试图在这两者之间取得平衡吗？
Yes. And look, the most recent park that we built in Shanghai, which opened almost 10 years ago, has a seven dwarfs attraction. Right. As a for instance. And it does, and the Pirates of Caribbean, there's a Pirates attraction, which Walt really conceived of in the 60s. at Disneyland, and there is a Tomorrowland. It's slightly different. So everything that we build today
是的。看呐，我们在上海建造的最近一座乐园，大约10年前开业，里面有一个七个小矮人的游乐设施。作为一个例子。而且确实有，比如《加勒比海盗》，有一个海盗景点，这是沃尔特在60年代在迪士尼乐园亲自构思的，还有一个“明日世界”。它略有不同。所以我们今天建造的一切
has reference to our own past, and I think carries forward basically the entertainment value of the original concept. But we have this incredible luxury of even more stories to tell as a company, so you'll see Marvel and you'll see Star Wars, and you'll see Avatar and all the great, a lot of great Pixar stories, including Toy Story Land and And we're building a monster's land in Florida. So it's almost endless in terms of what we can build. But I think what you will appreciate is while the past is present, the present is present. And we're hinting at a future.
都参考了我们自己的过去，并且我认为它基本上延续了最初概念的娱乐价值。但作为一家公司，我们拥有讲述更多故事的不可思议的奢侈，所以你会看到漫威、你会看到《星球大战》、你会看到《阿凡达》以及所有精彩的皮克斯故事，包括《玩具总动员》园区，而且我们正在佛罗里达建造一个怪兽电力公司园区。所以就我们能建造的东西而言，几乎是无止境的。但我认为你们会欣赏的是，虽然过去历历在目，但现在也同样历历在目。而且我们在暗示未来。
We're building a currently, actually, we haven't started building, but we're conceiving of the park we're going to build in Abu Dhabi. By the way, a part of the world we have never really planted a flag in. We're extremely excited about it. And this will be a park that utilizes technology at almost every level to design and ultimately to build. And then for people to experience. And that's incredibly exciting for our Imagineers. As you expand, do you feel that Disney becomes, and this is a strange thing to say, but becomes less American.
我们目前正在建造——其实我们还没开始建，但我们正在构思即将在阿布扎比建造的乐园。顺便说一句，那是我们从未真正插过旗帜的世界某个角落。我们对此感到极其兴奋。这将是一个在几乎各个层面都利用技术进行设计并最终建造的乐园。然后供人们去体验。这对我们的幻想工程师（Imagineers）来说是极其令人兴奋的。随着你们的扩张，你觉得迪士尼是否变得——这是一个奇怪的说法——变得不那么“美国化”了？
Do you think, I mean, certainly under your stewardship, Disney has become this genuinely global entity. I mean, I'm not saying you're in danger of losing your Americanness, because I'm sure you never will, but do you think the perception of Disney as American is, it feels less American to international consumers than what has done 30 years ago? It's not purposeful on our part to become less American. It is purposeful on our part to become more inviting to the world and to be mindful of cultural distinctions and cultural, really, passion, really. So, for instance, when we were building Shanghai, the brief, the design brief that I gave to the team was, let's build something that is authentically Disney, but distinctly Chinese, which in the design process and the build process, we thought about, it was our mantra, really, because we wanted to build something that was very much Disney to them, and they had an idea in mind of what a Disneyland would be, but something that was extremely respectful of their own. own culture so that they could feel as though it were theirs, not, and I don't think it's viewed as American in any way. Again, it's more purposeful to fit in in a respectful way. Like letting the French drink wine.
你认为，我的意思是，当然在你的领导下，迪士尼已经成为一个真正的全球实体。我的意思是，我不是说你们有失去美国属性的危险，因为我确信你们永远不会，但你觉得国际消费者对迪士尼是“美国化”的看法，是否比30年代时感觉不那么美国化了？变得不那么美国化并不是我们刻意为之的。我们刻意追求的是变得对世界更加包容，并铭记文化差异和文化上的真正热情。所以，例如，当我们建造上海迪士尼时，我给团队的设计简报是：让我们建造一个既原汁原味是迪士尼、又带有鲜明中国特色的乐园。在设计和建造过程中，我们考虑到了这一点，这实际上成为了我们的座右铭，因为我们既想为他们建造一个非常迪士尼化的乐园（他们对迪士尼乐园应该是什么样有一个既定概念），同时又极其尊重他们自己的文化，这样他们会觉得这是他们自己的，而不是……我不认为它在任何方面被视为美国化的。再次强调，更有目的性的是以一种尊重的方式去融入。就像让法国人喝葡萄酒一样。
Yes, letting, and I think there were lessons learned there in building Paris, as you call it as the Miracle on the Marne, which I know is referenced to something in World War One. Yeah. There, I think there were learnings about entering a country and a culture with a little bit more sensitivity and respect. And actually, we took those learnings seriously. And as we designed Shanghai, we made sure that we didn't make mistakes that have been made in the past. And can I ask, so I was just reading about the building of Disneyland's and Walt, despite having an excellent mustache himself,
是的，让……而且我认为在建造巴黎迪士尼乐园时吸取了一些教训，你们称之为“马恩河上的奇迹”，我知道这是对第一次世界大战中某个事物的引用。是的。在那里，我认为吸取了如何带着更多的敏感和尊重进入一个国家和文化的教训。事实上，我们认真对待了这些教训。当我们设计上海迪士尼时，我们确保没有犯过去犯过的错误。请问，我刚读到关于建造迪士尼乐园的事，沃尔特尽管自己留着漂亮的胡子，
forbidding people with facial hair to work there. Are you still pugnophobic in your attitudes to your workforce? Or can you have a beard and a mustache? Yes, I don't know whether I'm afraid or proud that I'm the one that changed that. I think, you know, he was, well, I really don't know exactly what he had in mind there, except I think he wanted, I think he probably wanted his cast members, we call them. You know, they're all performing on a stage of sorts to be very clean looking. And maybe very American, I don't know.
却禁止留面部毛发的员工在那里工作。你在对待员工的态度上依然存在“恐须症”吗？还是说现在可以留胡子了？是的，我不知道自己是该害怕还是该骄傲，因为正是我改变了这一点。我想，他当时……我其实并不确切知道他心里是怎么想的，除了我认为他可能希望他的演职人员——我们这样称他们。你知道，他们都在某种舞台上表演——看起来非常干净清爽。也许非常美国化，我不知道。
I don't think there's anything un-American, by the way, about facial hair. Certainly not today, but as I think in the, you know, 20 years ago when I became CEO, it was clear that banning facial hair actually limited the number of people we could hire. Yeah, you couldn't have on Custer World. Yeah, yes, the Custer had a hell of a mustache, right? Well, the ride I would love to see is a ride based on the generals of the First World War. And you can have some of those Russian generals with their enormous moustaches. Moustache adventure.
顺便说一句，我不认为面部毛发有什么不美国化的。当然现在不是了，但在我20年前成为首席执行官时，很明显，禁止面部毛发实际上限制了我们能雇佣的人数。是的，你不能在卡斯特世界里录用了。是的，卡斯特可留着一幅了不起的胡子，对吧？好吧，我最想看到的游乐设施是一个以第一次世界大战将军们为主题的游乐设施。你可以让其中一些俄国将军留着他们巨大的胡子。胡子大冒险。
Yeah. This is why you guys do the rest of history and we build team parks, right? I suspect it probably is. I thought it was just practical for us to allow facial hair. And we still have grooming standards, by the way. You know, we haven't completely abandoned our desire to show up looking good. Very like us at the rest of history. some. Very right. So Bob, thank you so much for giving us this time. But the torture for you
是的。这就是为什么你们去研究别的历史，而我们建造主题公园，对吧？我猜大概是这样的。我原以为允许留面部毛发对我们来说只是很实用。顺便说一句，我们仍然有仪容标准。你知道的，我们并没有完全放弃展现良好外表的心愿。这很符合“历史其余部分”的风格。非常对。所以，鲍勃，非常感谢你抽出时间给我们。但对你来说，折磨
is not over yet because you're taking us. Fresh excitement's the come. Yeah, you're taking us to Disneyland. And I have to say, I cannot wait. But thank you so much. Well, you're welcome. It's not torture for me, obviously. If I get spent every day at Disneyland, I would be a very happy fellow. Thanks very much for listening. And as you heard in this episode after that interview, Dominic and I went to Disneyland and you can watch footage of that visit and our tour of Walt Disney's office on YouTube now. Simply click the link in this episode's description or head to YouTube and search for the rest is history. Yes, I really advise people to do that because they'll see the greatest moment in the history of the rest is history, which is our producer
还没有结束，因为你要带我们去。新鲜的兴奋即将到来。是的，你要带我们去迪士尼乐园。我必须说，我已经迫不及待了。非常感谢。不客气。对我来说这显然不是折磨。如果我每天都能在迪士尼乐园度过，我会是一个非常快乐的人。非常感谢大家的收听。正如你在本期节目中听到的那样，在采访结束后，多米尼克和我去了迪士尼乐园，现在你可以在YouTube上观看那次访问以及我们参观沃尔特·迪士尼办公室的视频片段。只需点击本期节目描述中的链接，或前往YouTube搜索“The Rest is History”。是的，我真的建议大家去看，因为你们会看到《The Rest is History》历史上最伟大的时刻，也就是我们的制片人
Theo Young Smith being detained by Stormtroopers at Disneyland. And you would expect Theo to sort of respond to this in a very swashbuckling and macho manner, but actually as you'll see if you watch the film, his actual reaction is very different. Luke Skywalker, he was not. He was not, exactly, yes. More C3PO, I would say. So listen, we will be back next week with an extraordinarily swashbuckling and exciting series on The Life of the Young Elizabeth the First. So if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you'll actually get all four episodes of that series on Monday. The rest of you, I'm afraid, will have to wait. And a final reminder, if you want to see Tom enjoying himself on the Pirates of the Caribbean ride and Theo Youngsmith
西奥·杨·史密斯（Theo Young Smith）在迪士尼乐园被风暴兵扣留。你会期望西奥以一种非常侠义和有男子气概的方式来回应这件事，但实际上，如果你看了视频就会发现，他的实际反应非常不同。他绝不是卢克·天行者。一点也不，是的。我可以说，更像C3PO。所以听着，我们下周将带着一个极其惊险刺激、关于年轻伊丽莎白一世生平的系列节目回归！因此，如果你是“The Rest is History”俱乐部的会员，你实际上将在周一获得该系列的所有四集。至于其余的人，恐怕你们得等等了。最后提醒一下，如果你想看汤姆在加勒比海盗游乐设施上玩得开心，以及西奥·杨·史密斯
being arrested at Galaxy's Edge, then click the link in this episode's description or head to YouTube and search for the rest is history. And believe me, you will not regret it. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Hello, I'm David Ullushog. And I'm Sarah Churchwell. This week, on Journey Through Time, we are exploring the story of the gunpowder plot of 1605, the story of how a small group of Catholics engaged in what would have been the most devastating terrorist attack in all of British history.
在银河边缘被捕，那就点击本期节目描述中的链接，或者前往YouTube搜索“The Rest is History”。相信我，你绝不会后悔的。再见。再见。你好，我是大卫·乌鲁绍格。我是萨拉·丘奇韦尔。本周，在《时间之旅》中，我们将探索1605年火药阴谋的故事，讲述一小群天主教徒如何策划了英国历史上最具毁灭性的恐怖袭击。
The plan was ruthless, blow-up Parliament, King James I, and most of his family, all in a single blow. The series will tell the story of treason and traitors, of a group of men led by the charismatic Robert Catesby, who believed that the only option left to them to win their rights as Catholics with the violent destruction of the Stuart State. We look at the story of Guy Fox, the nation's most famous traitor, from his recruitment to becoming the plot's fall guy, and ultimately being tortured and killed. Finally, we find out why this plot is still remembered now 400 years later. Listen to journey through time wherever you get your podcasts. George Orwell was one of the most impactful voices of the 20th century.
这个计划冷酷无情：在一瞬间炸毁议会、詹姆斯一世国王以及他大部分的家人。本系列将讲述叛国与叛徒的故事，讲述由富有魅力的罗伯特·卡茨比（Robert Catesby）领导的一群人，他们认为赢得天主教徒权利的唯一出路就是暴力摧毁斯图亚特王朝。我们将探讨盖伊·福克斯的故事，他是这个国家最著名的叛徒，从他的招募到成为阴谋的替罪羊，最后遭受酷刑并被杀害。最后，我们将探讨为什么这个阴谋在400年后的今天仍然被人铭记。在各大播客平台收听《时间之旅》。乔治·奥威尔是20世纪最具影响力的声音之一。
But do you know what? His life story is just as interesting as the things he wrote. I'm William Drimple. And I'm Anita Arndon. And we are the hosts of Empire, a goalhanger show about world history. And on Empire, we're currently in the middle of a gripping four-part series about the life of George Orwell. Allwell's early life was wrapped up in the British Empire. He was born in India to an opium trading father, and in his 20s, he served as a colonial police officer in Burman.
但你知道吗？他的人生经历和他的著作一样引人入胜。我是威廉·德林普尔。我是阿尼塔·阿南德。我们是《帝国》的主持人，这是一个关于世界历史的Goalhanger节目。在《帝国》节目中，我们目前正在播出一个关于乔治·奥威尔生平的扣人心弦的四集系列节目。奥威尔的早年生活与大英帝国紧密相连。他出生于印度，父亲是鸦片商人，在他二十多岁时，他曾在缅甸担任殖民地警察。
His later life crystallised his hatred of totalitarianism. As an idealistic writer, he travelled to fight with the Republicans against Franco's fascists in the Spanish Civil War, and he witnessed the horrors of the Blitz. These experiences led him to write his most famous novels, Animal Farm and 1984, giving us enduring phrases like Big Brother, is watching you. To listen to our miniseries now, subscribe to Empire, wherever you get your podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他后来的生活彻底激发了他对极权主义的憎恨。作为一名极具理想主义的作家，他前往西班牙内战中与共和派并肩作战，抵抗佛朗哥的法西斯分子，并目睹了大轰炸的恐怖。这些经历促使他写出了最著名的两部小说《动物庄园》和《一九八四》，为我们留下了诸如“老大哥在看着你”这样流传后世的名言。现在就订阅Empire在各大播客平台收听我们的迷你剧。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。